[Music]
but still sex power money in a super
interesting world professional
basketball visit hey it's good to be
home Devils nation rise up we put it on
the fourth wave how much are the
character is going to be haunted by
their past going into season four ah man
you know what that's a good question I
would say a lot of the cast members
including myself is gonna be haunted by
the past like Devils on Reno's built on
an ancient burial ground no one's safe
yeah I feel like a lot of characters
come up even if they're not there their
spirits may haunt you and also you also
get to see as they evolve the past
characters you always get also get to
see how when these new characters come
in how they may stir up some things
I mean the last thing we saw from him he
was released from prison due to the fact
of someone else you know coming forth I
feel like there's only one way for
Germany to go up you know to me like
there's only one way for him to go after
this and that's up and you know it's
it's it's time for him to basically
figure out what it's what's best for
German all this dark time and he's went
through in the last season and I think
now everyone just wants to see like you
know Jeremy back on the bright side
something fans might not want to see
though Jude with someone who's not zero
if you're gonna kiss me kiss me I wasn't
gonna kiss you episode 1 we're gonna get
a chance to meet Noah so who is the
better kisser zero or Noah oh boy you're
putting me on the spot huh you're
killing me with this question telling me
I'm gonna have to say Noah for sure
hands down now bias or anything no no no
Wow good question okay yeah I'm gonna
say no I feel like Noah comes in at the
perfect time and his personality is one
that meshes with his I think there's
kind of like a yin and the yang going on
and that creates some drama
eventually are things moving a little
too fast with you and Noah what do you
think I think you might be trying to get
Brent fired no I'm just joking get me
into a trap no um it's I feel like it
comes down to what I what I said early
is he knows who he is now there's no
hiding there's no height literally
hiding in a closet there's none of that
he knows who he is and it's just gonna
be a big long adventurous journey to
grab opportunities when you can Derek
would say that Tiana and Kendall's
characters could be a lot like the new
Asha and Elena so what do you guys think
to that Asha and Elena are two specific
people that you can't replace but I
think ultimately like you build on the
shoulders of giants I think Taylor and
and Logan did such a great job with what
we've done
kendall and tiana have taken the
responsibility of only competition I
feel like this year both these girls are
bringing flavor to the show and the
dancing is different the energy is
different in a great way I have to say
I'm learning a few dance moves from
these girls which I've never did a death
drop I had gotten hurt work uh and she's
my trophies get a lot better season four
I better know how to move the booty okay
removing booties - moving on expect
Lionel to get her groove back this
season I'm new here
drinks me time cuz I wanted to give to
Jodi and for and for all the cast that
came back stuff that really pushes and I
mean this is a part of vinyl that we
haven't seen but this year when he told
me before we started he said you're
single okay and you said no really
single you're mingling but you're single
yeah but I'm mingling a lot he said
that's what you need to know going into
the new season
[Music]